[Music]
you don't enjoy the commercial breaks
now we actually have our commercial
breaks last for exactly as long as the
commercials will last on television so
notice that yeah we actually have and
it's a nice time we have if the
commercial break is three minutes long
it's three minutes of me and I wander
through the crowd and give gifts and
money and apparently have not been here
before no I spent a lot hours at home
making marzipan treats and I give them
to people and there's a lot of rubbing
of bodies and it's it's very sensual you
don't have if you have a three minute
break on your show you don't have a
three minute break in the audience is
that right we don't know it's about
three seconds when I say we'll be right
back it goes and we're right back okay
and then later on they just photos they
put that in on their own time why have
you chosen to do that well I don't I
don't like being out in front of people
if I don't have something to do I mean
you just sit there for like three
minutes and what do you do you've got
250 people staring at you and you don't
have [ __ ] to do I mean what do you I'm
basically very shy and I don't have
anything to say and so I don't like to
take commercial breaks so we don't do it
I love him if I could take more
commercial breaks I would I'm only alive
when I'm in front of an audience I'm and
so I love it I love that time and I I
sit here and they look at me and I know
they have to look at me they have no
choice
[Applause]
true story we have people in the
audience who occasionally look away and
we have the pages wander through the
aisles with sticks and like look at him
but you like commercial breaks you like
because of the commercial break then you
talk to me for three minutes you don't
really want to talk to me I do doc you
don't you don't want to talk to me I
like you don't you know if you wanted to
talk to me you would call me during the
week I don't you don't call me during
the week you've never come by my house
on a Saturday afternoon you see what I'm
doing
get over that effing pothole on a
Saturday you own in it the gate well
first of all Conan at the gate why would
I go to the gate unannounced and clang
on your bell that doesn't sound very
inviting you know you're gonna just let
those dogs loose and they're gonna come
and rip my face I don't call you don't
come by you don't care what I think
about the weather or the Cowboys you
don't you never called me during the
week I really don't care what you think
about the weather and the Cowboys I
honestly don't but I would love to hang
out with you if you were to invite me to
your home I would go [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm going oh yeah invite me and I'll go
all right invite me and I'll go I will
all right do you get by the dogs we'll
see ya notice the minute you said I will
no eye contact
[Applause]
you